las medidas extremas regresan a europa
este lunes austria se convirtió en el
primer país del continente en
restablecer un cierre en medio del
aumento de la propagación del virus en
la nación que sólo cuenta con un 66 por
ciento de la población vacunada una
medida que para muchos es un retroceso
dramático
sinceramente he llegado a mi límite
física y mentalmente a causa del crono
vivo
en alemania los contagios aumentan y los
hospitales están al borde del colapso
por lo que el gobierno está preparando
nuevas medidas como la suspensión de los
mercados navideños e intentando
incentivar a la población a vacunarse
con una dura advertencia
hay una posibilidad de que al final de
este invierno prácticamente todos en
alemania estarán vacunados curados o
muertos como algunos dicen cínicamente y
estonia mientras en bélgica han
enfrentado manifestaciones en contra de
las restricciones por el virus que
registraron una afluencia de al menos 35
mil personas y terminaron en
enfrentamientos con la policía gozo
cañones de agua y gas lacrimógeno para
dispersar a los manifestantes
manifestó que una manifestación acaba en
una ola de violencia como estas
inaceptable y desde luego es inaceptable
que la violencia sea contra la policía
si sergio alonso en un solo país una
situación es similar a la de países
bajos donde han detenido al menos a 30
personas relacionadas con los disturbios
contra el coi 19 este fin de semana todo
mientras una nueva ola del virus amenaza
el 'viejo continente' a medida que se
acerca el invierno